Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
3D printing is a rapidly progressing research
field. One can create colorful patterns that
we call textures on different figures with
Computational Hydrographic Printing, just
to name one of many recent inventions.
We can 3D print teeth, action figures, prosthetics,
you name it.
Ever thought of how cool it would be to design
robots on your computer digitally and simply
printing them. Scientists at Disney Research
had just made this dream come true.
I fondly remember my time working at Disney
Research, where robots like these were walking
about. I remember a specific guy, that, well,
wasn't really kind and waved at me, it has
blocked the path to one of the labs I had
to enter. It might have been one of these
guys in this project. Disney Research has
an incredible atmosphere with so many talented
people, it's an absolutely amazing place.
So, in order to get a robot from A to B, one
has to specify scientific attributes like
trajectories and angular velocities. But people
don't think in angular velocities, they think
in intuitive actions, like moving forward,
sideways, or even the style of a desired movement.
Specifying these things instead would be much
more useful.
That sounds great and all, but this is a quite
difficult task. If one specifies a high level
action, like walking sideways, then the algorithm
has to find out what body parts to move, how,
which motors should be turned on and when,
which joints to turn, where is the center
of pressure, center of mass, and many other
factors have to be taken into consideration.
This technique offers a really slick solution
to this, where we don't just get a good result,
but we can also have our say on what should
the order of steps be. And even more, our
stylistic suggestions are taken into consideration.
One can also change the design of the robot,
for instance, different shapes, motor positions,
and joints can be specified.
The authors ran a simulation for these designs
and constraints, and found them to be in good
agreement with reality. This means that whatever
you design digitally can be 3D printed with
off the shelf parts and brought to life, just
as you see them on the screen.
The technique supports an arbitrary number
of legs and is robust to a number of different
robot designs. Amazing is as good of a word as I can find.
The kids of the future will be absolutely
spoiled with their toys, that's for sure,
and I'm perfectly convinced that there will
be many other other applications, and these
guys will help us solve problems that are
currently absolutely inconceivable for us.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!